jack ma is one of the few men in the
entire world who have been able to
create over one trillion dollars worth
of value in the market he's the man
behind some of the largest chinese
companies including alibaba the end
group and sign out hearing this i don't
think you'd be surprised to hear that
jack was the richest man in china not
too long ago with a peak net worth of
61.2 billion dollars over the past two
years however his net worth has tumbled
nearly 50 to 32.3 billion dollars
at first glance it's easy to dismiss
this as the side effects of a weak stock
market or an economic downturn but if we
take a closer look at jack's story we'll
see that this downfall was anything but
natural you see it the reason jack ma
has been getting destroyed is actually
because he said some not so great things
about the ccp or the chinese communist
party obviously the ccp was not very
happy to hear about his perspectives so
they decided to teach him a lesson and
if you thought jack's decline in net
worth was already pretty bad
well that's the least of it the ccp has
gone ahead and demolished the valuations
of all of his companies take alibaba for
example in october of 2020 alibaba
reached a peak valuation of 858 billion
dollars by march of 2022 however alibaba
would shed 77 percent of this valuation
crashing down to 206 billion dollars
that works out to a market cap loss of
652 billion dollars and that's just
alibaba moving on to the ant group this
company was just about to ipo right
before all of this drama unfolded and
according to forbes it was realistic to
estimate up to a 470 billion evaluation
but once jack shared his comments
beijing would halt the ipo and
essentially force jack to hand over the
company to the ccp it appears that jack
tried to stall this as much as possible
but he eventually caved in all the way
in late july today fidelity values the
ant group at just 70 billion dollars
which is 400 billion less than their
projected ipo valuation
if we added this market cap loss to
alibaba's market cap laws we get a total
market cap loss of 1.05
trillion dollars with a t
and that's just jack's largest companies
if we throw all of his other smaller
companies into the mix we'll see that
jack has endured a market cap loss of
1.1 to 1.2 trillion dollars within the
past 24 months his losses alone are
enough to create the world's sixth
largest company so what in the world did
jack do to deserve such a punishment
taking a look back all of jack's
problems can be traced back to one
fateful speech on october 24 2020 at the
bun summit jack was well aware of the
weight of what he was about to share so
he started off with a little disclaimer
he asserted that his views are probably
immature incorrect and laughable he also
suggested that people should simply give
him a listen and if he doesn't make any
sense they should just forget about
everything he said with that out of the
way jack began discussing the role of
china in the global economy he argued
that china had to basically become
someone that fills in the gaps left by
the west for example the west does not
want to take on low paying manufacturing
jobs so china fills in the gap similarly
the west does not want to pollute their
own ecosystems with the factories so
china fills in the gap jack argued that
instead of filling in the gaps left
behind by the west china should look to
fill in gaps in the future this way
china could stop being a follower and
start being a leader to most of us this
probably seems like a fair thing to say
but to the ccp this comes off as
criticism today jack is essentially
saying that the ccp is making china into
a follower instead of a leader moving on
to jack's second point he went on to
discuss how we need to take
responsibility for the future this part
of the speech would have probably been
okay if it wasn't for this one quote
from president xi jinping apparently the
president told jack success does not
have to be with me
i think it's quite possible that
president xi jinping really did mean
what he said but i don't think he
completed his full thought i think the
full thought to go something like this
success does not have to be with me but
control does by sharing just the first
part i think jack gave his peers and
everyday chinese a sense of freedom that
the ccp was not a fan of if this
statement didn't push the ccp over the
edge the next part of jack's peach
definitely did as jack would go on to
outrightly criticize the chinese
financial system he said today's
financial system is a product of the
industrial age in other words he was
suggesting that china's financial system
was centuries behind the nail in the
coffin was we cannot regulate the future
with yesterday's means there's no
systemic financial risks in china
because there's no financial system in
china the risks are a lack of systems by
this point jack was already done for and
it was probably best if he stopped
talking but he would go on to talk about
the ccp's least favorite word reform the
new financial system is the direction of
the future
no matter whether we are happy or not it
will definitely rise no matter whether
we do it or not someone will do it in
the future i believe that reform is a
sacrifice and a price after that
statement jack almost sounded like a
revolutionary for obvious reasons the
ccp is not a fan of revolutionaries and
they would make that crystal clear in
the coming weeks and months
shortly after jack's hero moment he
would be invited to a closed door
meeting with chinese financial
regulators as he would guess this
meeting was not to go through his
proposed changes it was actually to
inform him that the ant group ipo would
not be allowed to take place in a
last-ditch effort jack would try to
bribe them with the stake in the ant
group you can take any of the platforms
and has as long as the country needs it
but the ccp was by no means willing to
let jack go so easily it was clear to
them that they had to make an example
out of jack to prevent other
billionaires from stepping out of line
and that's exactly what they would do
after canceling the ant group ipo they
would cancel out all of his public
appearances they even replaced him as a
jaja on his own talent show called
africa's business heroes that would be
like america's got talent replacing
simon cowell with todd's consent over
the next few months jack would
completely disappear from the spotlight
and this is why we got all those
articles asking where's jack the
official explanation is that jack was
simply laying low while things were
haunt but it's very possible and that
jack was detained or even tortured even
if jack wasn't beaten there's no
question that his companies were being
beaten on december 23 2020 china would
launch an anti-trust investigation into
alibaba for suspected monopolistic
practices around the same time they
would tell the ant group that they need
to substantially reduce their scope they
were instructed to stop pursuing the
insurance and wealth management sectors
and simply take the payment services
china would also move to make the ant
group a state-owned operation china
would force existing shareholders to
give up half of their equity to six
outside shareholders this included a
fifteen percent stake the nanyang
commercial bank five percent of china
huang asset management and ten percent
to canada united bank a few months later
china would hit alibaba with a record
2.8 billion dollar fine they would also
delete alibaba's internet browser from
the app store alibaba's browser was the
second most popular web browser in china
before it was deleted while such moves
were no doubt painful most of the damage
actually came from how people perceive
these moves you see customers and no
investors want to be associated with
chinese companies that aren't friends
with the ccp
so they both started leaving it in
droves i mean it just look at what
happened to alibaba stock the worst part
was that jack's actions didn't just hurt
his own companies but all chinese
companies jack speech made it clear to
the ccp that they had not only given
jack too much freedom but all
billionaires too much freedom so they
thought it was best to punish them all
and if you don't believe me just take a
look at the nasdaq golden dragon china
index
this is an index of 30 of the strongest
companies in china and this index wasn't
down 20 30 40 or even 50 percent it was
down at 76
and we still don't know if the bottom is
in
clearly it jack has created quite a
disaster
once the initial damage had been dealt
to jack's companies the ccp switched
their focus to destroying his legacy and
the way they've been accomplishing this
is by stripping him out of all of his
positive associations for example one of
jack's contributions was creating a
university called hapon university in
2015. the university was a business
school focused on creating the next
generation of business leaders
jack felt that this was china's version
of harvard business goal and there was
no doubt that it was an extremely elite
school after all you needed to own a
business that was pulling in at at least
4.5 million revenue per year to even
apply to this school this cola is no
doubt one of jack's proudest
contributions but the ccp has been
actively trying to dismantle the entire
thing first of all they forced the
school to suspend enrollments then they
removed jack as president of the school
and finally they forced the institution
to drop the word university from its
name the new name of the institution is
the hapon innovation center all of these
moves are clearly geared to discredit
the institution as much as possible jack
paul was one of the main factors
attracting students to the school and if
he's no longer associated with the scola
why would anybody bother joining jack's
goal was for hoppon to run for 300 years
but at this point it's not clear if a
pond will even last 30. in the meantime
alibaba has resorted to trying to bribe
themselves back into the ccp's good
graces late last year for example
alibaba announced that they would make a
15.5 billion dollar donation to china's
common prosperity fund for perspective
it this figure was equivalent to
one-third of their entire cash reserves
this just shows how desperate alibaba is
to get back on the ccp's good side the
ccp of course accepted the donation but
it doesn't look like alibaba is in the
green just yet
more likely to not this is gonna be a
several year journey for alibaba to
slowly earn back their freedoms and jack
will have nothing to do with it
today it seems like jack has more or
less accepted his fate he rolled the
dice with the ccp and the ccp has shown
him who's truly on top
at this point he still got plenty of
money but he's lost everything that gave
him purpose whether that be his talent
show or his university or even just
control over his own companies the ccp
basically told him you went too far
we'll let you keep your money but you're
gonna have to give up everything else
for a lot of you this probably doesn't
sound that bad
i mean in the end he does still have 30
billion dollars so things could
definitely be a lot worse
looking forward if jack simply sticks to
enjoying his wealth inside china he
probably won't have any further issues
if he tries to invest his money into a
new business or new endeavor however the
ccp probably won't be very happy and
they'll likely start this whole takedown
process all over again in this time they
won't leave him with any money either so
for his own good i think it's best if
jack sticks to private jets and mansions
instead of change and revolution but
that's just what i think if you were
jacket would you have criticized the ccp
comment that down below
also drop a like if you're not a fan of
the ccp
and of course consider checking out our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]
you